hello I'm Adrienne Aiken and I'm in the
UK I'm doing this video submission
interview thing and it's been a while
since I've done any of these so please
excuse if I whoa okay um
introduction done I think they both not
getting it how long have you been a
screenwriter
um well three months no well I started
about 15 years ago actually roughly when
I first got the bug and I really wanted
to write and I did I wrote on my first
sort of screenplay it took a while I
didn't have a computer it was all in a
book and I used to take my book
everywhere and especially to my local
little Park outdoor cafe and sit there
and people watch and write this idea
ideas that became one film script and I
loved it it was funny I'd read its
people and they'd laugh and it was funny
very naive but very funny and then I had
a break-in at my house and the book was
in a rucksack and they took the rucksack
to take all the stuff that they want to
disappear cheese broke me I couldn't
rewrite it I couldn't face thinking
about all the dial of course have no
backup anything so it would all gone and
I just couldn't face rewriting it and it
kind of made me think right go back to
my day job my day job has always been in
music writing production so great still
a creative medium I always love my work
but I've just really wanted to write but
this was like bang and it just threw me
and broke me and I didn't care about
what they sold in the house or stuff but
I couldn't face rewriting it wanted a
rewrite something else but didn't have I
had ideas but I just didn't have the
heart I guess so I stopped and got on
with my day job which was really busy
anyway
didn't really write much more than that
for a while and then I saw a series on
TV behind the times it been out a while
but I just saw a repeat of an episode
and was blown away completely and that
doesn't happen to me very often at all I
got blown away by this series on all
counts I mean everything the writing was
incredible the direction was incredible
beautiful camera sets design the
cinematography the set everything
continuity music ah blew me away the
whole creative process and of course the
actors the whole creative process was
for me I was my jaws on the floor and
and I just wanted to be a part of it and
it kind of regurgitated this yearn of
inside that I had this yearning to do
this desire to write and I just want to
be a part of it so I I started writing
again I actually wrote an episode for
the series which I which is not going to
happen because the writers so but but it
got me to write an idea for something
else as a kind of inspired by which was
was the calling obviously and it just
totally totally set me up to write again
with all all of the mojo fire burning
and inspiration that I haven't felt in a
very long time so that started in
November and I actually wrote the script
for this for the series in a month
I know it's quick but the ideas were
torrent it was a torrent of ideas having
soaked up this when I went on board a
box set I got so obsessed by this this
thing and I never buy boxes I'm not
bigot le addict to be honest and so and
I went and bought the box set and got
completely absorbed by it so I did write
the the the Epis my episode very quickly
and then of course it was probably quite
nice but that gave me the idea for the
new one and so now my my how long we've
been working on your current script from
December again that flew together once
I'd got the idea the nucleus and I did
some research on bits and pieces I mean
yes I'm not easily distracted at all and
I went and that flew together and it
wasn't for me it wasn't cuz I was trying
to rush it it just was a torrent of flow
of ideas and I'm eternally grateful for
that because it's one of those things
you don't feel like you've done it it's
like it was there and I just was the
vehicle and I was just getting it down
and then re reading it and redrafting it
and analyzing it and then seeing bits of
advice and imply applying that to the to
the draft I've done and realizing where
I'd kind of done obvious blunders and
stuff and then I submitted it covering a
few questions here well anyway and then
I submitted it for to script readers to
get it analyzed professionally that was
good that came back with some very
encouraging especially for a first-time
writer really some very very very
encouraging stuff that was like they
could see the legs and it had legs and
it was going to run if I got a few
things some major some minor formatting
stuff as well sorted
some additions and subtractions
subtractions bundling up in this I had
to go and do all that so and that took
what felt like six months of giving
birth to triplets
I could imagine or pulling teeth that
felt that was the hardest thing I think
I've ever done creatively in my life was
a rewrite
not because I was precious but just
because you change one thing and it's a
game of dominoes you know one thing goes
and oh it tips over that and everything
else changes because everything's
relative to everything else isn't it I
mean you know it's all flow and it's all
part of cause and effect so you change
and effect and you have to change the
cause and then so that took a while but
it was actually only three weeks but
it's free look look Panda lack of sleep
I was thinking if I had a production
company I was gonna call it glamorous
Panda I like my glam and I hope and rise
so anyway um how many been working done
that why did you write it cuz it needed
to be told
okay I wrote it because I was incredibly
inspired and when I say inspired I
haven't for all my music stuff when I
was really young when I was really young
I used to feel that inspiration to
create right for me not just for other
people and produce for other people
sorry and I hadn't wanted to I wanted to
you know the idea of opening the
computer after you finished the day's
work was horan to me I just didn't want
to do it so that inspiration had kind of
got squashed and gone to just get up and
be creative
whereas
after I got inspired by this series oh
my god it was all I wanted to do and it
revitalized me and it really was like a
phoenix rising out of the flames for one
of a better dramatic it's like being
reborn my whole creative self came out
again and it felt brilliant it felt
great and it still feels great and for
all the ripping of you've got to change
this and you've got to do that it is the
best feeling in the world why did you
write it
and because it's a story to be told and
it's very current it's very now and it
must be told and it needs this this it's
a TV series obviously and it's very
current and it's very now and it's very
important and funny why haven't you quit
on this script
cuz I'm obsessed
and because I love it and I'm loving the
process I'm loving the passion that it's
given me I'm loving the inspiration I'm
feeling I'm loving the I'm loving
feeling like I did once when you run
again in that way what you'll go with it
to have the series optioned
made green light it'll happen very soon
and then yes so have the pilot picked up
on I need to get an agent so the first
goal is to get an agent I know who I
want they're not small and they're very
picky I'm sure they all are and I really
want these guys because they have some
really good people on their books and if
that ties us in this can be made really
well so I'd like to get in with some
really good people who have really good
people and can pull together really good
people and then sell it to
good people and I think it would be
great if it was sold and produced in the
same way as the one inspired me one
lesson screenwriting has taught you one
that there's many lessons to learn God
is there yes you one less than screen go
with your passion
stay with your passion don't ever give
up and don't forget to learn oh and
don't be precious you cannot be precious
you have to be open minded and you have
to accept the pros advice but hold your
ground with your passion you know I
think I don't know I might be wrong
the main lesson is never stop learning
never close your mind to it when do you
write at night it's when the world's
quiet it's when no one's gonna call me
and say why haven't you done my track
and it's when the ones that won not the
world sleeps my world my UK one is
asleep which means it's quiet you know I
think it's not just its quiet but the
vibe is quiet so I can focus because as
you probably noticed I can get easily
distracted
so yeah at night is when I'm most
inspired and unfortunately sometimes
once I'm on a roll it just keeps rolling
for hours 2 3 4 5 6 7 sometimes and
sometimes just oh it's my I better get
coffee
tell us a story about your screenwriting
career no no what are your screenwriting
goals
Oh what was your goal with it what your
screenwriting goals what was the goal
with the script what my screenwriting
goals to carry on writing hopefully many
more series of this series and I've got
other ideas I'd like to UM I'd like to
get on with them sometime but I really
want to write and I really want to work
with good people I think that connection
with talented people out there and
people that float your boat mine anyway
that connection to me is that connection
is everything you know when you work
with people and you it's like jamming in
music when you jam with a bunch of
musicians you don't know what you're
gonna do it's not preordained you just
get together and you create something
out of nothing and you both speak the
same language through the medium that
you're doing but it's just like I love
it I love it so I want to be able to do
that with people I respect that respect
me
that we love what we do and create some
amazing work initially on this series
then a story about your screenwriting
career I think I just have over my
probably covered it I think given that
time doesn't really exist maybe I should
tell you about my future screenwriting
career really successful writer and I'm
really grateful for it thank you so much
the universe thank you so much to
everybody that supported me and I have
to see what the Oscars